[Musique]
on va applaudir nos invités du soir
astrid veillon et nissan
[Applaudissements]
et ça vous êtes le roi de l'impro
j'essaye de vendée merde ça va faire
trois scènes trois scènes avec des
situations différentes
vous allez en faire une avec bernard
montiel une avec gilles verdez et une
troisième avec enora vous allez voir
apparaître un thème à l'écran quand le
thème apparaît vous vous retournez vous
nous faites une petite scène vous
découvrez que vous êtes jumeaux rêvait
j'en rêvais mais c'est pas croyable été
chercher ça fait 20 ans mais ça fait 30
ans que moi je cherche je savais que 22
ou amusants des 32 plus orienté rien
compris dans les 22 frérot or tous les
mamans comment elle va bien elle est
morte
moubarak
outre foudre pendant une boum alors pu
tâter golez
[Musique]
la chine suit voici le roi [ __ ] aime
les gens comme moi j'en ai bavé pour toi
ma chérie esquive passant si tu ne veux
pas moi aussi je te veux je te chercher
partout
c'est vrai ça fait la nation'' la fia
[Applaudissements]
est coincé dans l'ascenseur avec un
problème d'haleine outre les blacks se
sont drôlement fort ici à un ton un peu
à un moment je voudrais crepel a assez
d'être lié à la nav
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
round je te quitte pour tondeuse mystère
josue suis désolé j'ai rencontré l'homme
de ma vie
ah bon cap read oui il s'appelle je suis
à sochaux
oui mais joshua oui mon frère louis et
on devine frère de mission de mes frères
mes frères celui qui fait je n'ai pas
pareil de mes frères oui il fait deux
fois moins mon poids je le sais et 2005
un rapport avec le page au bout de vingt
ans la lassitude et un salaire mais on
ne pleure pas à me fleurs passe en
supplie embrassement au moins une
dernier oui mais est-ce qu'on peut pas
mettre juste les sardines
parce que c'est ma soeur
qu'est ce que les crs chargent
il en ira ce n'est pas de l'amour qu'est
ce qu'on est serré au fond de cette
boîte de sardines sont
un bar par loin de tout ça joshua a tué
mon demi-frère et ça donne
[Musique]